okay this is the how to lose a guide in
10 days reunion that I always wanted
your love Fern it didn't die
our loafers didn't die
not this one what type of memories did
it just dredge up kind of being back
together on set oh
I mean there's so many it was such an
impressionable time too for us we're
just you know really starting out and
babies and when I've met Catherine the
first time I felt it felt familial it
was like family you know and we had so
much fun with my first movie oh my gosh
I know I'll never forget being like
first of all hey I was like that's a
good
second of all I was like she's so normal
and so cool and so just the best like
the best we just became like it just
felt like I just always was like hey
that's an is a miracle that was like the
thing I would always say to people when
anyone asked me about you because I was
like I just think she's a miracle and
then just to come full circle and just
see her I can kill it pardon my French
freaking kill it in this movie it's like
just not literally there's no spoilers
but maybe who knows a baby we don't know
nobody knows anything any questions
Halle Berry
that has a kick oh my God what happened
[Applause]
police it's just so thrilling just
thrilling so anyway just all just oh
Steve I feel the same about cats so it's
just really the best that movie was
really big like really big you know what
you know what's fun about How to Lose a
Guy my son is now off and running in
college which I can't believe she's so
crazy and in the movie you didn't even
exist with now the new generation
they're now discovering the movie and so
all of the kids in college are like I
Love How to Lose a Guy and I'm like this
is this movie just keeps going
which is really nice yeah it is because
we also had so much fun I mean we had a
great time yeah we did I will say I
couldn't find the exact dress but my
prom dress was inspired by the Indiana
Oh it's yellow oh it's a pretty iconic I
didn't think that dress could be top but
I do have to say the birdie dress
there's a lot of Birdie the fashion
Lottery that you shout out to Jenny Egan
costume design Jenny I mean we when I
walked into the fitting which was
probably a very different experience
than you had
Catherine I laughed like I walked in and
it was just like someone had thrown just
like colors and prints and sparkles all
over the fitting room and then Catherine
had like a rack of beige it was just
like beige and then just like it was
like pencil dress yes a beige one piece
bikini I mean
no a robe tanks oh it was so funny but
this is why the knives out clearly the
first one you had all these costume
moments and then Jenny Egan just brought
it again amazing unbelievable I mean
Daniels oh Daniel's costumes in this
movie are like on another level even his
like I don't know if it's a swimsuit or
what but I love it it is oh that is a
swim on yeah that's it on a swim
Ensemble the swim yeah right a swimming
swim creation yeah ladies and gentlemen
for at least one person this is not a
game
so Catherine in the movie you attempt
the Benoit Blanc accent sure have you
been able to nail it since then can
either of you do it Benoit blanc no
clearly
[Laughter]
please turn that into a meme
oh
that was amazing I can't do it either
come on
Blanc oh that's good he sort of has a
way about how he moves his math right
yeah right right it was like oh you
would sufferable buffoon
you're all friends why would anyone
commit murder
are we even going to talk about the
elephant in the room
am I the elephant yeah you're the
elephant you're not that bad which of
your cast members would you entrust to
hide a body with you I mean I kind of
trust almost everybody no yeah no this
cast is I feel like we as an ensemble
would work so well together to I would
trust this group but I feel like I'd go
to you first yeah no yeah I would
immediately there's a problem yeah who
would you let tweet from your phone for
an entire week Leslie oh yes class Class
Act he is Daniel is absolutely not
Daniel would be a devout you'd be like
oh my God ah you throw into everything I
don't even think does he even have
Twitter No but he would have so much fun
he would have thoughts on Twitter yeah I
don't know I'm not on Twitter are you on
Twitter no I'm on nothing oh that's
right what's that like I'm just like I
know I know totally fantastic probably
yeah I don't know I'm your best life
yeah but I lurk around I mean you know
I don't have a fence stuff someone just
I mean how late am I to that party I
don't have a finsta and I have one now
see I don't have that that would be fun
because then I can look at people's
Instagram yeah both your characters have
such distinct personalities did you base
them on any real life person not for me
yeah you know I mean I did definitely
birdie I mean even though I'm sure a lot
of people will see kind of someone they
know or an idea of something in birdie
for me it was just really I mean he
wrote I wanted to bring what I could
bring to what Ryan put on the page and
not kind of complicate it with trying to
think about someone else I felt like she
was an amalgamation of people that I've
yeah I mean to be honest unless I'm
playing someone who's like a real live
person I'm kind of like that I don't
want any references it's like writing
music but like listening to other
people's music while you're writing
music it feels a little bit like you
stay out of that you know so you can
bring something new
foreign
[Music]